hello guys I'm Greg
we're gonna watch today a couple of
videos from Suicide Squad the Harley
Quinn extended look and the Joker
extended look why talk anymore let's do
this
start with Harley Quinn this Joker's the
one everyone really wants whoa
sexy
you're going somewhere very bad and
complete the mission you get time off
your prison sentence fail the mission we
died she seems nice Oh
Oh stable golfers Steve don't face
seriously the hell's wrong with you
people for bad guys that's what we do
Suicide Squad rated pg-13 experienced it
in IMAX 3d you know I gotta tell you the
more I see em Margot Robbie was Harley
Quinn the more I'm loving it I grew up
on the Batman animated series wasn't
that long ago where I rewatched the
whole series I bought all the DVDs and I
rewatched the entire thing she is
ringing Harley Quinn to a real life
point it seems like it's a good hybrid
performance of sort of the realism world
the kind of like when Nolan set up I
know this is separate from the Dark
Knight trilogy there seems to be a
hybrid of kind of what DC's doing now
with their movies combined with that
realistic interpretation I'm sure with
like getting David AR on board that
really helps I feel like Margot Robbie's
like gonna kick ass in this role I think
the card the cartoon characters like way
more hyper and active but this is real
life she's bringing the action alive
she's got the sexiness down on a Harley
Quinn I know it's not the traditional
outfit but this kind of street attitude
that she has it seems like a lot of this
movie of Harley Quinn is not going to be
Harley Quinn and the Joker while we're
obviously gonna get some of that I'm
excited a really going either way to
show that Harley Quinn is her own
character that could actually stand on
her own even without the Joker there
Joker compliments are significantly more
but I think that Margot Robbie's going
to kill it now let's move on to what I
really want to see Joker extended look
already from 0 seconds it looks kind of
creepy
this is not just her
everybody's disappeared you know the new
hotness head off these bars gonna get
the child I can't wait to show you once
toys
using a psychotic antisocial sweetheart
careful
oh nice
ah
ah ah oh that's the new lap that
everyone's gonna try doing now so I'm
gonna have to get that down I'm gonna
have to get that down yeah
Warner Brothers Suicide Squad comes on
in a couple weeks
no more Joker in the trailers it's good
it's good stop stop no more joke
obviously a lot of people are gonna be
comparing this to Heath Ledger's Dark
Knight performance and it serves a
comparison from that this Joker seems a
lot more like kinetic when I watched The
Dark Knight again not long ago I kind of
realized like yeah Heath Ledger's you
know energetic and kinetic and stuff but
he's rather got he's like [ __ ] together
you know like he he doesn't seem like
too emotional about [ __ ] most of the
time I feel like this Joker gets like
really emotional you know in terms of
like anger and excitement this Joker
seems like he definitely has like some
mental disorder like I'm even getting
hints of like some type of manic bipolar
disorder a split personality disorder
when Heath Ledger came on to be the
Joker it had been many many years since
Jack Nicholson did his interpretation of
the Joker so we had a lot of time to get
that image out of our head I feel like
your letter has to suffer the
consequence of being compared to Heath
Ledger because it's still like rather
strong and fresh in our minds as
performance Heath Ledger's this one kind
of has like a punk rock vibe to it I
feel like in terms of the context of the
film though that Jared left he's Jay
Leno knows what he's doing he's a great
actor he's gotten better over the years
and I was like one of the best actors
around right now I really feel like
Jared Leto won't disappoint write me
down bury me bury me at subscription
services subscribe please I like it
thank you you're kind calling me at the
greg gala on instagram and twitter at
the real rejects facebook and twitter i
one of your shout out to Jared Leto
Jared the first guy I ever did anything
with sexually was a dude named Jared his
name was spelled differently so I don't
think of him when I hear your name but
now I will
I was weird telling my life